today on the mattwell show as war
continues to rage in ukraine our media
asks the important question how will
this affect trans people also joe biden
delivers his state of the union speech
it was a pointless spectacle aside from
one significant moment that we will
discuss today plus russia is banned from
the world cup that sounds fine to me but
didn't we just hold the olympics in
china there would seem to be some
inconsistency here plus in our daily
cancellation the creator of the 1619
project gets herself cancelled again and
i'll explain why it's doozy all of that
and much more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
so what does our current out of control
inflation look like looks like paying 47
more for fuel than a year ago looks like
paying 41 more for the same used vehicle
if you buy it this year instead of last
it looks like almost 10 percent more to
feed your family
looks like every dollar in your savings
is worth less than it was a year ago but
you can hedge against the us dollar by
investing in something with real value
gold and silver from birch gold precious
metals have historically been a safe
haven in times of inflation and birch
gold is the leader in converting iras
and 401ks into tax sheltered ira backed
by gold and silver with thousands of
satisfied customers and an a plus rating
with the better business bureau birch
gold can help you protect your savings
text walsh to 98 98 98 to get a free
info kit on gold there's no obligation
to get this info text walsh to 98 98 98
to get your free info kit now
so we're not going to begin the show
today with an analysis of joe biden's
state of the union address mostly
because the state of the union address
was as always boring pointless and
stupid it's also grotesque to have to
witness once a year the monarchic
spectacle of an alleged public servant
parading down the aisle to unearned
adulation
walking up the platform only to deliver
90 minutes of propaganda interrupted by
fits of scripted applause the tradition
ought to be abolished but it never will
be because the presidency only attracts
narcissists and megalomaniacs because
those are the only kinds of people who
would want to be present to begin with
and they're also the last sorts of
people who would ever forego an
opportunity like this so we're stuck
with it forever there are those who will
defend the state of the union saying
that well it's good to hear the
president address the nation and you
know give an update on how things are
going but these people have apparently
not noticed that every state of the
union address ever delivered
has ended with an assurance that the
state of the union is strong
you've never heard of state of the union
address where at the end the president
says in summation we're screwed
so what an incredible coincidence that
literally no matter what is happening in
our country no matter what crises we're
dealing with the guy in charge always
thinks that things are basically going
well
we know that's what he's going to say
it's what he always says and it
politically is he's required to say it
so there's no reason to say it or for us
to listen to it
there were however a couple of notable
moments from the address notable in the
in the ways that were not intended
however and we'll talk about them a
little bit later instead today
i want to begin with um a news item from
cbs about the war in ukraine only cbs is
not focused on the aspects of the
ukraine situation that most people would
be concerned about
they've put aside minor distractions
like death destruction
untold human misery etc and so forth and
they've zeroed in on what really matters
here's the headline
a war within a war a transgender woman
says transphobia and discriminatory laws
are keeping her hostage in kiev during
russian invasion
yes we are lurching towards a
cataclysmic global war and if you think
that's bad already imagine how
transgender people feel about it
indeed the worst thing about any
potential nuclear holocaust is the
impact it would have on the transgender
community
the cbs report is quite hairy harrowing
it reveals how the conflict in ukraine
has led to a misgendering crisis
it's like a genocide but with pronouns
let's read some of the articles it says
ze fam
that's the name
that i'm sure i pronounced correctly was
born and raised in crimea an area of
ukraine that was invaded and taken over
by russia in 2014. now the 31 year old
lives in kiev the capital city that has
been under russian siege for nearly a
week she's running out of food and
hasn't left her house for days as
gunfire erupts outside and she says she
can't leave
family who is transgender said that
transphobia is pervasive in the city in
neighboring countries and fears that if
she leaves the tension of the ongoing
conflict will make her more susceptible
to violence
family was previously a popular
contestant on the ukraine singing
competition star factory and family
doesn't know what to do even if she
doesn't face violence on her way to the
border she has no idea whether she'll
even be allowed to leave the country
quote there's no way ukrainian border
poli people can let me through she said
there's no way if she makes it to the
border of a neighboring country offering
refuge she's not even sure if they'll
let her in as her passport indication
does not match her gender now apparently
the problem that z faces is that he
wants to flee but ukraine is not
allowing males to leave because um
they're needed at home to fight and
defend their country and but he doesn't
want to do that he wants to leave with
the women and children but he's running
into the problem that technically he is
neither a woman nor a child
the article continues quote for years
transgender people in ukraine who want
to be legally recognized had a long list
of steps they had to go through to do so
according to human rights watch the
government mandated that transgender
people undergo extensive psychiatric
observation and and uh undergo gender
reassignment surgery to get legal
documents that aligned with their gender
legislation was introduced in 2017 to
lessen the process but still would
require that transgender ukrainians
undergo outpatient psychiatric
examinations there is no indication that
that legislation was ever implemented
quote i don't want to go through that
this is like humiliating for the world
family said i decided to keep my
passport keep mailing my passport and
now i cannot leave the country
but we're told
ukraine was bad for trans people even
before war broke out in fact uh we're
told it was hell listen
sometimes we think it's just all a dream
that we
stuck in
inside some kind of a video game because
you just you live in a quiet society and
then you hear bombings and then you wake
up to the sound of bombings i don't want
to go outside
i'm literally scared for my life
all my friends left the city my
neighbors left
my floor and i think my building
[Music]
this is not a very rainbow friendly
place so lives for trans people
are very
bleak here
[Music]
if you have male gender in your passport
they will not
let you go abroad they will not
let you through
a war within a war truly truly
every noise from outside
is a warning sign
it was hell living as a trans person and
keeping gift in ukraine we feel
invisible
truly like we're not people like we're
not human it's truly how we feel
you know um i wonder
if a ship was sinking and women and
children were allowed to evacuate first
and a man um said he was a woman and
tried to board one of the lifeboats out
of turn
would we pity him
when he's caught and not allowed to get
on the lifeboat or would we condemn him
as a coward
these days i'm not so sure
and there are a few takeaways from this
bit of propaganda from cbs and that's
one of them
the trans agenda as always is intensely
obsessively self-centered cities in
ukraine are in the process of being
shelled and raised to the ground and
this person is not only trying to leave
rather than defe then defend his home
but also taking the opportunity to
complain that there's not enough
tolerance for his gender identity
next perhaps we'll hear complaints that
the ukrainian government is failing to
supply free hormone replacement therapy
you know people also can't get food or
other provisions because their cities
are under siege
but let's let's keep our priorities
straight you know
but this alleged lack of tolerance for
trans people in ukraine raises a larger
point i think
ukraine according to this report anyway
does not really accept transgenderism
their culture rejects the philosophical
notion that a person can change their
gender simply by declaration
they'll still let you be recognized as a
different sex if you undergo the
operation and submit to psychological
evaluation a concession that goes
farther than i would go if it were up to
me
but generally speaking they do not have
the same attitude about gender that we
do that we have in this country
and our media wants you to be shocked by
that
but what they don't want you to realize
or think about
is that the vast majority of the world
doesn't look at gender the way that
people do in our society we are the
outlier not ukraine
venture outside of western culture and
you'll encounter a whole world that
still believes males are men and females
are women
the lion's share of the world's 8
billion people currently on earth right
now all live under this assumption
and have always lived that way
leftist gender ideology just like crt
which we'll discuss more later
is
an incredibly insular
specifically western uniquely modern
phenomenon until about 60 years ago it
didn't exist at all anywhere here or
elsewhere now it exists in our culture
has taken over our culture but most of
the world has continued to see gender as
it had always seen it this is especially
true by the way of non-white parts of
the world
ukraine is one thing go down into say
africa
and you'll find many places where
transgenderism is truly invisible
because it doesn't exist at all
we should stipulate then
that gender ideology is insular western
modern and mostly white
so here's the great irony
the left spends so much of its time
militating against everything it
perceives to be uniquely white and
western and yet in reality it is trying
to spread those exact things across the
world
leftists in the west have been
conducting their own invasion for many
years all across the world attempting to
export their half-baked and incoherent
ideas to every corner of the globe into
countries and regions that don't
understand it
don't want it don't need it
the cbs report is a call basically to
extend that campaign into ukraine
if the country survives the russian
invasion it will now have to endure an
invasion of a different sort
a philosophical one
a kind of ideological colonization
which will lead to a different kind of
destruction
but nonetheless very real
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know tax time is always stressful
but this stress can magnify if an
identity thief steals your info files a
bogus return and pockets your refund
that's kind of insult injury the irs
recommends electronic filing and using
their pin tool for extra security other
safety tips include looking out for
phishing scams um checking your
financial accounts regularly for unusual
activity and setting up two-factor
authentication as well every day the
point is we put our information at risk
on the internet in an instant a cyber
criminal could steal what's yours
sometimes even harm your finances your
credit your reputation that's why it's a
good thing there's lifelock lifelock
detects a wide range of identity threats
things you wouldn't be able to find on
your own uh like if you're not checking
the dark web for your social security
number being for sale that's what you
need life lock for if they detect your
information has potentially been
compromised they'll send you an alert
and you also have access to a dedicated
restoration specialist if you do become
a victim so you get protection on both
ends of this thing nobody can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can help protect what's yours with
lifelock by norton join now and save up
to 25 off your first year at
lifelock.com walsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 percent off
okay now we will begrudgingly head over
to the state of the union address and uh
the big the big controversy today after
about the state of the union address is
uh not anything that happened
um
during this you know on stage as it were
but it's that um there was an
interruption apparently by marjorie
taylor greene and lauren bobert bobert
congresswoman
who shouted something during a speech
they kind of heckled joe biden
and
um they shouted something about
specifically about the i believe the 13
u.s service members who were killed in
afghanistan
and they died because of the hamfisted
way the encampfisted incompetent
way that joe biden handled the pull out
from afghanistan
and this is supposed to be a big a big
uh you know big controversy is it what
what a what a horrible thing for them to
desecrate this sacred event by
interrupting the
president the two things about that
before we get to the speech itself
number one
you know i'm glad that somebody brought
up
those service members who were killed
because joe biden wasn't going to talk
about it
and you know someone had to bring it up
and number two the state of the union is
not some kind despite all of the
pageantry that goes into it it is not a
sacred holy event who cares if they
interrupted it i wish it was interrupted
more
you know that would at least make it
more entertaining i wish that there were
people
shouting the entire time
we get the interruptions of of scripted
canned applause
yeah every once in a while there's a boo
but um yeah i wish that there are people
shouting
the entire and i say that i don't care
if it's if it's a republican or democrat
because every year you get a you get a
dumb controversy like this where you
know there's always there's one person
in the audience who interrupts who says
something
and it's true that it often times if
it's a republican president who gets
interrupted
then um
you're going to have outrage the next
day from a lot of conservatives and say
how dare you i i don't care this this
event deserves no
uh
you know
it does not deserve our attention at all
it doesn't deserve our reverence
this is how politicians ought to be
treating each other i think
this kind of foe putting aside even the
issue of all the pageantry
and the kind of
the way that this is all a
holdover from a kind of monarchy
perspective
um it's also the foe unity
let's get everybody in a room together
and we'll hear the president talk about
how we're all united as one
we're not we're not enemies of each
other he said that too
he said that at one point we have to
stop treating each other as enemies
which is an interesting quote coming
from the guy
who um
had just a few months ago said that pta
moms are domestic terrorists and now
he's saying we're not
enemies so the whole thing is a show it
doesn't mean anything it's it's it's
totally empty
i wish i wish you should just be
shouting the entire time interrupting it
because that's the level of respect
that it deserves and also again it would
make it a lot more entertaining for the
rest of us
so um we'll move on to this there was
one moment of real honesty i thought in
the speech itself
and let's play uh clip 22.
we are also ready with antiviral
treatments
if you get covered 19 the pfizer pill
reduces your chances of ending up in the
hospital by 90 percent
i've ordered more pills than anyone in
the world has
pfizer is working overtime to get us a
million pills this month and more than
double that next month
i've ordered more pills than anyone in
the world has that i believe
he forgets to mention that they're
mostly for they're mostly for him in his
own medicine cabinet so that part i'll
believe a little bit of honesty there
this part was less honest um
as we got towards the end of the speech
and joe biden finally
um
threw in
the radical leftist stuff and uh with
with democrats and state union addresses
this is what they always do
you know maybe god forbid one day when
alexandria casa cortez is president or
something then we're going to get the
full woke experience for the entire 90
minutes
but that's not typically what democrats
do they'll throw it in there but it's in
a very euphemistic way and they just
mention it and they move on because they
know how
actually unpopular these ideas are
especially if you talk about them in any
kind of explicit way
so towards the very end
um he threw in a bit about abortion and
listen to the way that he uh that he
talks about this listen
if you want to go forward not backwards
we must protect access to health care
preserve a woman's right to choose and
continue to advance maternal health care
for all americans
[Applause]
maternal health care for all americans
let's just stop and think about that for
a minute now
a lot of euphemisms surrounding the
abortion issue
because as i said they can't talk about
it honestly they can't talk about it
explicitly they can't say what it really
is
which is that you are destroying a life
and that's not my opinion or my
perspective there's something subjective
about that that is what you are doing
that's why the women go and pay 400 to
the abortionist that's that's what
that's what the procedure is for is to
end a life
because if if it was not if there was no
life to end then you wouldn't need the
abortion
um and it is violent and it is bloody
and it is painful
for everybody involved especially the
child is being killed
um
because of course in the abortion we
don't recognize the child as being a
human being so there's not even going to
be any steps taken to make sure that the
execution is painless for the child
because if you take any of those kinds
of steps then you're acknowledging that
there's a life there that there's a a
person and you can't do that so it is
brutal and painful and awful and it's
and barbaric
so they're always covering in euphemisms
and we hear a lot about the reproductive
rights this is about reproductive rights
reproductive health as i always say
about that
this has nothing to do with reproductive
rights or reproductive health because
abortion does not stop reproduction
you know abortion kills the child after
the child has already been produced
so it's too late now to talk about
reproduction that's already happened
cons the the the reproductive act the
moment of reproduction is at conception
you you're not going to find any doctor
or scientist who will tell you that
birth is reproduction
so that's usually what you hear but but
now
joe biden calls it maternal health care
which is just
perverse and grisly i mean this this is
this is pretty grim stuff
maternal healthcare
because you're you're acknowledging
that the woman is a mother
you're acknowledging that the child
exists that she's the mother and this is
a this is a
a maternal health care procedure
so in a way that is a little bit more
honest
actually
because at least you're acknowledging
that this woman is a mother
and when she gets the abortion
um she's not gonna this this isn't that
you're not turning back the clock you're
not reversing anything
you're killing the child now she's the
mother of a dead child
so in a way i guess i would prefer now
that i think about it i'd prefer for
them to use that euphemism of maternal
health care than to call it reproductive
rights
because now at least you're even if you
don't mean to you're admitting
that abortion is not a health care
decision it's not a medical decision
it's a it's really a parenting decision
you're making a decision as a parent to
kill your child
um
and then there was
i think what this was probably the
biggest moment of the speech uh a moment
of defeat
this is the moment
and it's really pretty incredible when
you keep in mind what's happened over
the last two years
this is the moment when the defund the
police movement officially died listen
we should all agree the answer is not to
defund the police
is to fund the police
fund
fund them
fund them with resources and training
resources and training they need to
protect their communities
i asked democrats and republicans alike
to pass my budget and keep our
neighborhood safe
fund the police is now the applause line
and almost every democrat
in the auditorium there is uh every
democrat in the audience
is applauding funding the police with
the exception the squad members they did
sit on their hands and they didn't they
didn't applaud but everybody else they
were on their their feet
saying let's let's fund the police now
just for fun
let's go back and remember uh this is a
compilation that's floating around on
twitter now and it's actually about
seven minutes long we won't play the
entire seven minutes but here's a good
90 seconds of one democrat after
another talking about defunding the
police this is what the democrats were
saying pretty much all of them for the
last two years listen
so we've been talking about defunding
the police there's some issues that we
ask police to do like mental health
issues or policing in schools and all
the rest that perhaps we can
shuffle some of that money around suck
it up defunding the police has to happen
we need to defund the police mayor eric
garcetti saying take some of the money
from policing about 150 million dollars
i plot eric garcetti for doing what he's
done not only do we need to disinvest
foreign police but we need to completely
dismantle the minneapolis police
department so yes defund your butts
defund you yes i support the
reallocation of resources
from nypd we will be moving funding from
the nypd to youth initiatives and social
services they are talking about reducing
the allocation of resources to that
department and i think every single
city in this country ought to be
thinking about the same thing yes i
support the defund movement i'm for
responsible
reallocation of resources and defund the
police i think you do all those other
things you don't need all the money
that's going in the police department so
yeah i mean the spirit of it i i i do
support that yeah and you know a lot of
us were asked if we could imagine a
future without police back in 2017 when
we were running for office
and i answered yes to that question we
are going to reduce funding in the
police department and redirect that
money there's no reason the police
budget should just keep growing and
growing and growing
i'm sorry did did corey bush say defund
your butts did i hear that correctly
i mean that i agree with if anyone's
butt is being funded by the government i
very much would want to see that funding
reduced at a minimum
but that's that's the democrats and
those are again it goes off for seven
minutes and that is not just the squad i
mean the squad might be at the at the
forefront of it they're the ones leading
this movement and the rest of the
democrat party the establishment
democrat party uh filed in behind them
and let them lead but these were
the most prominent democrats in the
country including nancy pelosi both on
the federal level on the state level
local level you know mayors governors
senators
congresswoman this is they were all
saying
defund the police
and what do you know it was a total
disaster
because it's not just that they such
that they tried to actually defund the
police for the last two years they
really did it
they they actually implemented this
policy in many cities
and we saw immediately the exact result
that any rational person would expect
when you put
fewer resources into enforcing the law
then you're going to have more anarchy
more chaos more law breaking
more people committing crimes
that's the equation it's not a very
complicated one this isn't calculus
but of course rather than
stand up there there was no chance that
joe biden uh who allegedly is this
decent and honest man uh but the decent
and honest joe biden there was no chance
that he would stand up there and say hey
listen
we thought that defining the police
would work it didn't
and we're sorry about that
and now we're going to go back to
putting some resources into these police
departments
now he's not going to do that instead
they it's just an applause line
one applause line one applause line joe
biden erases the last two years
of total disaster
and he's able to do it because he has
the media on his side all right before
we move on um
in the run-up to the state of the union
camilla harris appeared on a radio show
and i just wanted to play this for you
if you haven't heard it yet uh she
appeared on a radio show called the
morning hustle
and she was asked to explain the ukraine
situation in layman's terms now
that is important context here in
fairness she was asked to explain it in
layman's terms
and she apparently thinks that the
average layman is uh in preschool
listen
if you're watching any level of news
even social media you're seeing
everything that's going on right now in
the ukraine break it down to layman's
terms for people who don't understand
what's going on and how can this
directly affect the people of the united
states so ukraine is a country in europe
it exists next to another country called
russia russia is a bigger country russia
is a powerful country russia decided to
invade a smaller country called ukraine
so
basically that's wrong
russia is a big country ukraine is a
little country
they're on a planet
called earth
earth goes around the sun the sun is hot
the sun is also really big
you can't touch the sun it will burn
thank you camila harris
uh that is her breaking and down to
layman's terms that's also as deep as
her own analysis and her own
understanding of the issue goes so uh
let's make no mistake about that it's
not just her patronizing and thinking
that americans are all a bunch of morons
i mean she does think that but this is
also she can't
listen to her on meet the press or
something and it's going to be a very
similar analysis as that okay uh moving
on we'll go over to uh ukraine well
we'll starting here actually with our
energy situation pete budageage
i want to play this for you and and uh
speaking of euphemisms you got to be
able to sift through
all of that to get to what's really
being said here
because buddha just asked about the fact
that uh well we're dependent on foreign
oil uh we're dependent on on russia we
import um
six hundred thousand
barrels a day
uh other european countries especially
dependent on russia so what can we do
about that and budage his real answer
once you get through all the talking
points in the lingo and everything and
the buzzwords his real answer is that we
should continue to intentionally weaken
american oil in response to this let's
listen to that
drill more open up more u.s land to
drilling what's the administration's
response to that idea
well look the the president has laid out
and taken a number of steps including
addressing the strategic petroleum
reserve
including diplomatic efforts to increase
global oil production and other ideas
that have been raised that are on the
table because everything deserves to be
considered but let's also be clear that
we are in the middle of a long-term
transformation that is already fast
underway especially when it comes to
vehicles uh making electric vehicles
more affordable for americans something
that the president has proposed and is
hoping congress will pass uh for example
under the president's proposal uh those
pickup trucks that started about forty
thousand dollars would have their prices
actually down to the high twenties with
the tax incentives we're proposing would
allow more americans to capture the fuel
savings that you get we don't know from
year to year what will happen in the ups
and downs of the global oil markets but
we do know that you are better off
financially
and less subject to maintenance and
repair issues if you own one of these
vehicles we want them to be american
made electric vehicles creating american
jobs on american soil
that's going to continue to be a policy
priority for this department and
administration even as we're acting to
provide more short-term relief okay all
right it's probably more of that than we
needed on second thought because there's
really only one word that you need to
hear
putting everything else aside peel all
that away uh the only word that matters
there is the word transformation and
that's what that's what you always have
to look out for
is he's he's saying well this is a this
is a transformation
and this is what the left always does
democrats always do they're always
looking for a moment of crisis
um in order to use it
to help transform america
and that's that's always their mission
it's never about preserving anything
it's never about saving it's always
about transforming
and uh changing it right in to to in
their image
mutating maybe a better word
and so that's really his answer
is that this is our opportunity to
transform energy
which in other words means
to make american oil weaker to destroy
the industry and uh again reshape
society in their image
now let's go to this from yahoo it says
russia will be barred from the 2022
men's world cup and other international
sports competitions after fifa and the
international olympic committee levied
extraordinary sanctions in response to
russia's invasion of ukraine
fifa soccer's global governing body
and uefa the sports european governing
body announced monday that they have
banned all russian national teams and
clubs from all competitions until
further notice spencer will likely
remove russia from march's world cup
qualifying playoffs and end its hopes of
earning a birth of the most prestigious
tournament in the international sport
now
if you want to ban russia from the world
cup fine with me where it works for me
sounds good
um in fact you'd go even farther than
that and how about ban all countries
from the world cup and ban everybody
from soccer and just get rid of soccer
entirely i think that's probably the
best thing that we could possibly do
but if you're not going to do that you
want to ban russia great i'm all for it
but i can't help but notice
that this is happening only what two
weeks
after the conclusion of the olympics
the olympics which were held in china
china which is a country that is
certainly guilty of not only guilty of
its own rampant human rights abuses
but also there's the little detail about
the fact that china unleashed created it
seems and unleashed a virus on the world
that killed five million people
and so after china has unleashed a virus
onto the globe
infected the globe with a virus
that killed five million people
it not only was allowed to attend the
olympics but but it hosted the olympics
and every other country showed up
and we all played games together and had
fun
oh but there was a there was a
diplomatic boycott
so some of the american diplomats they
didn't show up and i'm sure that their
presence was sorely missed
and china they really had their feelings
heard about that i'm sure
but we still showed up there
so once again you know we're getting
tough with uh russia when it comes to
some of these things anyway
still not not all that tough because
we're you know
we're still importing all the oil we're
gonna dump the vodka down the drain but
still import the will
but um
in spite of that when it comes to china
still hosting the olympics we went to
the olympics and there was almost there
was almost no discussion about that's
what blew my mind the entire time
there was some discussion about
the human rights issue
which is good
there was at least discussion about the
fact that china commits all these human
rights abuses
but that to me was like the less
relevant point compared to the fact
that they that they created this virus
in a laboratory and and let it go into
the world and kill 5 million people
and that detail when it comes to the
olympics wasn't even talked about
just uh absolute
hypocrisy and moral inconsistency
all right um let's go to this there's a
local news report in seattle we go from
china russia ukraine let's go back to
the united states where there are some
things happening here that i think
deserve our attention a local news
reporter in seattle took a drive
downtown over the weekend
to show what a typical evening in
seattle looks like we have that uh
okay here's this is this is seattle
and this is not
the set of a zombie apocalypse film this
is not walking
the walking dead this is
actually an american city
and you just see trash garbage littered
everywhere
people using drugs in the middle of the
street
uh people hunched over
like zombies under the influence of
drugs
look at that i mean this this is what
american cities look like right now
this is not just uh that's one street in
one city that is one street in one city
but many streets in many cities look
exactly like this if not worse
this is what is happening in america
what you're watching is the full-scale
collapse
of american cities
and american civilization as well
so at a certain point maybe we should
have some concern about that maybe we
should start talking about that
maybe we should actually try to fix that
you know i was watching the state of the
union last night and i saw
all these lawmakers
both uh both republicans and democrats
were carrying ukraine ukrainian flags
and some of them were decked out you
know it's like they were at a soccer
match or something and they were decked
out and even more than that there was
like i think i saw some people face
paint or something and just they had the
pins and everything
for ukraine
showing their support for ukraine
which all right
but you just don't see that kind of
concern
and patriotism for our own country
just like our politicians are very very
concerned about the borders of ukraine
protecting the borders of ukraine
those same politicians have basically no
concern at all for our own borders
this is one of the reasons why we can't
get sucked into
conflicts across the globe there are a
lot of reasons one of them is that it
will result in thousands if not millions
of american deaths
but the other is we just can't afford it
in in any
way we are not in a position
unfortunately to go solve the world's
problems i wish that we were i wish that
that was possible i wish that we were
doing so well that we could afford to do
that
but we're not
because what you just saw that's what
our cities look like right now they're
collapsing
and we think we can fix the whole world
we can't even fix seattle
maybe that's where our focus should be
before we get to the comment section i
want to read this this is from gulf news
it says
his highness sheikh mohammed bin rashid
al maktoum vice president prime minister
of the uae and ruler of dubai on tuesday
inaugurated the museum of the future
which is being called the most beautiful
building on earth
dubai's new iconic landmark officially
opened its doors to the world with a new
message of hope for all mankind now this
is being hailed
at least in dubai
as the most beautiful building on earth
let's take a look at this there it is
that is
that's the most beautiful building in
the world
it looks like a
giant misshapen donut
or maybe like a very
large piece of playground equipment
my my kids would love to climb that
thing i think that's that's one thing i
can say for it
but is this the most beautiful building
in the world
if we're talking about modern buildings
like buildings that have been built in
the last 20 or 30 years then it's in the
running only because modern buildings
are almost always hideous
because at some point we decided this is
part of our the collapse of our
civilization we decided to stop building
beautiful things especially beautiful
buildings
and it didn't used to be that way we
used to strive to make every
building beautiful we used to strive to
make everything beautiful that we could
have you ever been inside like a post
office that was built 85 years ago
even just standard government buildings
um before modern times were beautiful
until modern times
that's not the case anymore but before
that i mean buildings either had
grandeur and majesty and a certain kind
of
drama to them or else they were quaint
and they had character
these days everything is bland and
workmanlike and when someone goes out of
their way to build something with visual
appeal like that whatever that
monstrosity is it ends up being
something like that like a giant krispy
kreme donut
because we've given up on beauty you
know when you give up on beauty that
means you're also giving up on truth
and i think we're experiencing that in
our culture as well now let's get to our
comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay i have to mention this
um
to give some credit to a member
of the sweet baby gang you know i
mentioned on the show a couple days ago
how um
i am uh
a
not the most talented athlete but i am
at least very good
at um
at beating my kids in basketball like i
i can i i probably can't measure up
against anybody else but when it comes
to squaring off against my
eight-year-old kids
i um i'm a champion and i think we have
that clip just to remind ourselves of
that let's play that
yeah i'll go outside to my driveway and
and i'll play basketball against my kids
but i can't derive any real meaning out
of the fact that i win
and i do always win because i never let
that win
no one's gonna give me a trophy for
being undefeated against eight-year-olds
in one-on-one basketball i'd take that
trophy if someone gave it to me because
it'd be hilarious but no one is offering
it
well
i thought no one was offering it but as
it happens a member of the sweet baby
gang
actually went and made me a trophy
matt walsh
basketball champion of eight-year-olds
uh he someone made this trophy for for
me delivered it to the office and so
there it is and uh i have to tell you
and this will be proudly displayed in my
office
you know every other trophy that i own
is a participation trophy from little
league
and i have like nine of them because i
participated in little league nine times
if you can believe it um and i of course
still proudly display those as well but
this trophy is actually the most
meaningful award that i've ever received
it actually is
it's the first one i've really earned
which tells you something about how
incredibly pitiful my life has been
and what a mediocre sad sap i am
still you take the accolades wherever
you can get them and the fact remains
that i am undefeated against my kids in
basketball and that includes by the way
one-on-one around the world horse
i've never lost
check back in like two years and we'll
see if that still is the case
um
let's see
austin says of both of matt's talents
both his best by far is his commitment
to mispronouncing names of people he
doesn't respect
well thank you thank you for for
noticing that is so
well that's my talent and my other one
is defeating eight-year-olds in
basketball so i need a trophy for that
as well
commenter mccomment face says zielenski
is the new andrew cuomo for march 2020 a
bunch of resistance wine moms cheering
for nuclear annihilation because
zielenski is cute and they hate trump
supposed
putin lover so stupid
yeah you know here's here's the thing
with the reaction to zelinski obviously
zielinski is defending his homeland
as he should
um
but it does
really rub me the wrong way the way that
people are a lot of people in this
country
are watching this unfold and engaging
it it's like it's like they think
they're watching an actual movie they
think it's a reality show
there were some i just saw some new york
post article about um and it said that
uh fans have been debating which
hollywood actor should play zelinski
when they make a movie about him fans
fans of what a war
war has fans now
so that's what uh
what i find so disgusting and
inappropriate
and also look zelensky i mean he's he's
been out there
trying to push
the rest of the world the western world
to get involved on his behalf on behalf
of ukraine he wants the no-fly zone i
mean yesterday he sent out a tweet where
he was comparing it to uh you know he
was evoking the holocaust and said that
hey
western countries you said never again
but uh but where are you now
and and once again
i understand why he would do that i mean
if i was in his position i would do the
same thing i would be trying to get the
rest of the world to come help because i
care about protecting my own country
but he's thinking about ukraine he cares
about ukraine not not america
and if it were up to him we would get
sucked into this thing even if it
results in thousands or millions of
american deaths
and that's another reason for us to
remain keep our head on straight
when we're watching this and we're
analyzing it
not to get swept up in emotion get
caught up in war fever
start looking at this like it's a movie
or something
because the rest of the people involved
in this they have their own interests as
they should
okay and that's what they're concerned
about
um people in ukraine they're concerned
about ukraine
which is why we in america we need to
keep our interests in mind also
because nobody else is going to
if we are not focused on protecting
america and if we are not focused on
american interests then no one else is
going to be focused on that
if that's not our first priority it
won't be anybody's first priority
and this is the kind of thing you don't
need to say it's the kind of discussion
it probably
doesn't happen in most other countries
across the globe
you wouldn't need to actually say that
hey you know we should prioritize our
own country first
you wouldn't need to say because it's
just obvious well of course we're going
to do that
only in america and other western
countries is this even a discussion
um
let's see
and uh finally
okay tony dh says matt what book are you
reading right now i'm reading in the
heart of the sea it's the the
tragedy of the whale ship essex is the
subtitle it's actually the story that
moby dick was based on or at least that
melville was inspired by
and it's about a whaling ship in 1820
that leaves nantucket and it sails all
the way down around south america and
ends up in the pacific and it's killing
whales the whole time and just that
right there is a you know enough fodder
for a good book i mean the life that a
19th century whaler lived willingly
lived
is extraordinary exciting bleak brutal
if you can imagine
like
trying to kill a whale in the middle of
the ocean
uh with 19th century technology
and you have to somehow tow the whale on
board and harvest it for oil just what
everything that went into that and then
anyway eventually when they're out in
the ocean they get attacked by a whale
they're stranded out in the ocean they
have to survive over thousands of miles
it's a great book and i would really
recommend it
you know in case you haven't noticed the
daily wire does not stop growing and our
latest show crane and company is just
more evidence to back that up craning
company is a daily sports show hosted by
former athletes and coaches jake crane
blaine crane and david cohn and they're
joining forces with the daily wire to
bring you all the sports you love with
none of the woke nonsense attached when
you tune into crane and company you'll
be getting in-depth sports analysis
informative interviews predictions and
wagers and constant live chat engagement
with fans tune in live today at 3 pm
eastern and every weekday at
dailywire.com or on youtube you can also
listen as a podcast on apple podcast or
your platform of choice and make sure to
subscribe and give the show five stars
if you like what you hear as well
also i've got to let you know that look
no book is too controversial for the
daily wire that's why we started our own
publishing wing called dw books and
we're excited to be publishing 12
seconds in the dark by sergeant
mattingly it's a true story of what
really happened the night of the tragic
brianna taylor shooting mattingly a
20-year police veteran takes readers
inside his department's response and
debunks the lies that have recklessly
been shared with the public
uh check out the trailer here it was
very chaotic it was very quick
instantly i knew it was shot brianna
taylor she was caught in the crossfire
of those bullets as soon as your brain's
registering it's already over the media
got so many things wrong in this case
saying we had the wrong apartment her
name wasn't on the warrant she was shot
and killed in her sleep in her bed these
are lies this is not true and all the
while you're hearing all these outside
influences from athletes and oprah and
ellen degeneres and kamala harris and
joe biden all those people coming and
attacking you putting your name on their
account saying he should be in prison
all these things that they have no idea
what they're talking about but they have
such influence the more we attack police
for doing their job the less good
qualified police you're going to have
[Music]
when you read 12 seconds in the dark you
will find out the truth of what really
happened the night of the briana taylor
raid
[Music]
you know in a world where voices like
his are censored this story is
incredibly important and we're so
grateful to have this brave truth-teller
on board the book releases march 15th
but it's available for pre-order now on
amazon or anywhere you buy books online
so go get your pre-ordered copy today
because i promise you it will sell out
and you don't want to miss this book now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so this has been in my cancel pile for a
few days i almost let it go because time
had passed but i can't because there are
things in life which are destined for
the daily cancellation this is one of
them it also fits in a nice kind of
symmetrical way with what we talked
about to start the show uh the left
trying to interpret world events through
their very narrow insular lens that
brings us to miss nicole hannah jones
who's the um new york times journalist
who brought us the 1619 project she won
a pulled surprise for her work on that
piece of thoroughly debunked agit prop
because a pulitzer these days is about
as meaningful as a teen choice award or
a nobel prize and maybe she'll win one
of those awards or all three for her
commentary on the ukraine crisis as far
as that goes jones is a little bit of a
tough spot because her mind is a vehicle
with only one gear it's a menu with just
one option a buffet where every dish is
the same she has one setting one lens
for viewing the world and it's the
racialized lens of crt
problem is that a war between ukrainians
and russians
would seem to fall outside of the crt
framework
these are two groups of europeans
fighting in a region of the world 6 000
miles away
crt has no insight to offer about such a
conflict because crt is among other
things incredibly narrow and blinkered
in its view of the ra of of race and of
the world
in fact it basically ignores the entire
rest of the world and pretends that
everywhere is just like the modern
united states
this is how crt disciples can for
example
claim that non-white people cannot be
racist because
racism is power plus prejudice and
non-white people don't have
institutional power
which is obviously false even as it
pertains to this country but it's even
more false across the mess the rest much
of the rest of the world
filled with countries where all of the
institutional power is held by non-white
people
there are no whites holding
institutional power in china
does that mean there's no racism in
china
that would certainly come as a shock to
anybody who's ever spent time in that
country
but these are the limits the limitations
of the modern american race hustler
and it's why jones had to struggle and
stretch to find a way to make the
ukraine situation
fit into her preconceived mold
and this was the best she could do
so in a series of tweets last week jones
made the case
that the concern for ukraine in this
country stems from anti-black racism
she tweeted quote every journalist
covering ukraine should really really
look internally this is why i say we
should stop pretending we have
objectivity and instead acknowledge our
biases so that we can report against
them many of us see the racialized
analysis and language honestly these
admissions have shocked this is
happening in european country are
ahistorical and also serve to justify
the lack of sympathy for other invasions
other occupations and other refugee
crises involving peoples not considered
white
now don't go don't don't worry it gets
much better by that i mean by that i
mean worse she says what if i told you
europe is not a continent by definition
but a geopolitical fiction to separate
it from asia and so the alarm about a
european or civilized or first world
nation being invaded is a dog whistle to
tell us that we should care because
they're like us to be clear we should
care about ukraine but not because it's
european or the people appear white or
that they're civilized and not
impoverished
all people deserve to be free and to be
welcomed when their countries are at war
now okay
let's first engage with this idea that
europe is not a continent
she would later go on to explain that
quote the entire continent is either
asia or eurasia i suppose that's not up
to me i'm just stating a fact about what
defines a continent
yeah just stating facts sure the
interesting thing about this fact is
that it not only is not a fact but even
if it was a fact it would still be
totally irrelevant
let's pretend for a moment that europe
isn't a continent
okay i mean how does that at all impact
one way or another the relevance of the
war in ukraine
but europe is a continent because a
continent by definition is quote any of
the world's main continuous expanses of
land
europe is one of the earth's main
continuous expanses of land and so it's
a continent
now perhaps she thinks that it's not a
continent because it's it's connected to
other continents
but if that's the case then the only
pure continents in the world are i guess
australia and antarctica
the rest of us exist in a giant muddled
mass of connecting expanses of dirt and
rock
it's true that the lines distinguishing
europe from asia were invented by human
beings
the lines are drawn on a map they aren't
carved into the actual ground for the
most part
but that doesn't make the lines
fictional
i mean dragons and unicorns are
fictional europe is real
you can go visit it i mean there are
certain parts of it that i would avoid
for now but you could go
besides if europe is a fiction then so
is africa
that continent and all of its countries
have also been defined by lines that
human beings have drawn
in this sense
race is kind of a fiction too
people have different skin colors in
reality but we as human beings are the
ones who decided to label those colors
and imbue them with deeper significance
yet nicole hannah jones and her crt
comrades would say that it's racist
to try and erase race in that way
it used to be considered progressive and
politically correct to say that you're
colorblind and uh you know you don't see
race and race isn't real that used to be
the the progressive thing to say
now that is itself a racist claim
according to the prophets of crt
this is the problem with um
the people who go around labeling
everything a social construct
they set the precedent that a thing is
meaningless if it's a construct
but they're unwilling to apply that
precedent consistently so what about the
rest of her claim
she says that we only care about ukraine
because they're white
well that's clearly absurd just a few
months ago the big story was the
situation in afghanistan and the
disaster that unfolded because of the
way that joe biden handled the pull out
there
people were quite concerned about the
plight of afghans who are not white
now it's true
that the concern didn't seem to last
that long
but it won't last in ukraine either
people are led by the media to care
about one thing and then another than
another
as the media jumps from one lily pad to
the next there's plenty to be said about
this pattern of intense yet fleeting
focus on one thing at a time in rapid
succession but you certainly can't call
it racist
now since we're on the subject of
prejudice
i should mention that this past weekend
in dc a russian restaurant called russia
house was vandalized and spray painted
with anti-russia messages
meanwhile people are dumping their vodka
down the sink
prominent members of congress like eric
swalwell have actually proposed rounding
up all the russian students in the
united states and kicking them out
listen to this
congressman you you say a pull from a
menu of options but we heard from a
former dni clapper less than an hour ago
it says uh the time for and i'm
paraphrasing here proportionality
incrementalism is over we heard from the
former defense secretary uh william
cohen
dump all the full gauntlet of potential
sanctions on putin why not do that
everything we do has to be aligned with
our allies and the fact that we were
able to get the germans to stop this
pipeline that's huge that's u.s
leadership on the international stage
and so we want to move with our allies
in nato but also countries like japan
who can you know take quite swift and
severe actions against russia but yes on
the table should be sanctioning putin
personally
completely taking them out of the
european and international banking
system which is known
as swift frankly i think closing their
embassy in the united states
kicking every russian student out of the
united states those should all be on the
table and vladimir putin needs to know
every day that he is in ukraine there
are more severe options that could come
now after 9 11 which was an attack on
our actual country
we heard and have continued hearing
quite a lot of outcry about alleged
islamophobia
after china unleashed a virus on the
world that killed hundreds of thousands
of our own people there was an outcry
against anti-asian hate
now are we going to hear similar
denouncements of anti-russia hatred
will the media follow these kinds of
stories with the same feverish interest
will people of russian descent be
granted victim class status
the answer is no of course how does that
fit in with nicole hannah jones's theory
according to her narrative
discrimination against white people
ought to provoke the most outrage given
that she says we only care about white
people
and yet the opposite proves true once
again
that's because her narrative is divorced
from reality entirely
she may not know much about geography
but we must admit that she is an expert
on fiction and that's why today nicole
hannah jones is once again canceled and
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
dailywire2022
today on the ben shapiro show a barely
conscious joe biden gives a completely
disconnected and discombobulated state
of the union address we will go through
every excruciating detail give it a
listen